lebron some real physical play in that
fourth quarter just some high level
basketball what did it feel like to be
out on the floor for that
felt like a finals game felt like both
teams was desperate
understanding the situation they both
put themselves in
and uh trying to get every extra
possession
you know execute offensively try not to
make mistakes defensively
and uh that's what it's all about you
got some great contributions from
players like kcp rajon rondo alex caruso
out there
what do you see out on the floor when
all the guys like that are clicking
i mean we're a team who just hold each
other accountable
kcp's three right by that bench his
layup
right there from the top of the key with
the shot clock going down
dole's finish and then doze uh
penetration to kick that kickback for
80.
and ac is just always he's all over the
court and
we needed every cent and every second
from our from our bench from our
starters
um and to get this nice get tonight's
win anthony davis also coming up with
some big defensive plays in addition to
the offense
when you were watching him do that
through the game you're i see you
in his ear what kinds of things are you
guys saying to each other
well i mean between uh me and a.d we
hold each other to
a standard that no one else can hold us
to and that's what it's all about
he challenges me every night i challenge
him every night doesn't matter if the
ball is going in
we have to do things to help our team
win defensive end offensive end
and uh he did that tonight he was
spectacular taking uh taking a challenge
on jimmy to start
and then anytime he got switched on to a
guard just containing them getting block
shots giving us
extra possessions offensively you were
tweeting in the middle of the night the
other night saying you couldn't sleep
your mind was still racing
you were trying to keep that edge you
now have an extra day's break between
this and the next finals game how do you
and the team keep the edge to close
things out
um because we understand what's at stake
i mean
the job is not done and um you know we
get an opportunity to get our bodies
back up underneath us with an extra day
of rest
but also keep our minds sharp you know
i'm looking forward once again to
looking at the film tomorrow
um do all around the clock treatment and
uh and treating it like we played
thursday
i must continue to get the work in i'm
gonna continue to not sleep
until the job is done so look forward to
the next match